Phenology, the word, comes from the Greek
word "pheno" which means "to appear" and is
usually comprised of the study of the timing
and the duration of events in the lifecycle
of plants and animals.
In California, perhaps the most iconic wildflower
is California Poppy and the flowering of California
Poppy once it is induced occurs on a daily
basis for weeks and even months under good
conditions.
And the petals open to reveal the pollen containing
anthers inside until the flowers are pollinated
at which point the flower will wilt, the petals
will fall off and the seed containing ovary
will rapidly expand to contain hundreds of
seeds to be disbursed by the wind when the
fruit opens up.
At the scientific end of the spectrum, is
flowering at the end of winter advancing?
Owing to the increased warmth that we're experiencing
during our ever shorter winters or are they
perhaps in some cases being delayed owning
to say a lack of water necessary for those
processes to progress normally?
So today we're here at Hastings Reserve to
conduct a phenology workshop.
People from around the community came in.
Scientists and just some members of the public
and they're reporting their observations online
to an online program that the National Phenology
Network created.
Essentially this program its kind of like
Facebook for nature.
Well we all recognize that there aren't enough
scientists in California or elsewhere to provide
enough phenological observations with enough
frequency to be able to detect small changes
from year to year and so for that we need
to turn to the public to contribute to the
statewide and the ultimately to the national
database as well.